[Music]
and we basically believe
that you live to work now that just
freaked a lot of people out so i'm going
to explain that because it's not exactly
like it sounds okay if i said you were
created to work
it would feel yuck but if i said you
were created to contribute i think you'd
start to go
okay i'm in i'm in so basically what i
believe is is that
we can just break down the human race
when it comes to purpose to two
major areas relational purpose
and professional purpose i say
relational purpose first
on purpose because we are created to
connect
right first and foremost so you and i
have purpose
in our relationships in our particular
relationship roles
husband father son friend
teammate on and on and on and on but we
also have professional purpose and what
i mean by that is
i think it's really obvious that we all
long to make a difference in the world
and so we do that in our relationships
so relational purpose and professional
and so i'm helping people realize hey
there's more to work than
the nine to five the 401k
there is real purpose whether you're a
plumber
a professor it doesn't matter if you're
a missionary
or you are a nuclear physicist all
work can be and should be
honorable that's the whole point that's
everything i believe the whole show's
about so the idea is that
this isn't working for worth that's all
about us
it's about working to contribute that's
about everybody else so when
a teacher shows up and whether she has a
bad day or not but she does a really
good job
yeah she may feel like she had a really
crappy day but she made the difference
in the life of a second grader in ways
that she may never know
there's purpose in our work it's about
showing up
to give yourself away so i say this very
simply you were created to fill a unique
role in your work you were needed that
means you're valuable
and that means you must do it somebody
needs you to show up to be the best
version of you to use the talents that
god gave you
to actually do work that creates a
result that makes other people's lives
better
so i'm sitting there either i got laid
off
after the crazy last few years and i've
just cobbled together 17 different gigs
trying to make it work
i'm just sitting at home collecting a
check i am
you and i just hosted the other another
radio show a little while ago together
um a martyr um i'm just going to sit
here in this dead-end job because it's
in the town that i'm comfortable in or
that my wife is comfortable i know my
husband is coming whatever
what do you what you just said is
profound and i want all the listeners to
get that and i have a list of questions
we're going to talk about but we're
already off
list and we're at question number one
yeah that's what the book is about that
yeah that's it how do you find that work
how do you find it what do you do
and then well then how do you get there
that's what the book is about
but so i i bet i've applied
to a thousand jobs in my life i got
addicted to applying for jobs because i
thought
that the cure to my
lack of feeling like i was contributing
to anything like i was making the money
that i
felt i was entitled to which is a whole
other nonsense i gotta it's for another
show
but i kept thinking that my my
completion
was somewhere out in another job and
what you just said was
all work is honorable it's gonna look
it's gonna it's gonna be me what am i
gonna bring to this thing
and i'm gonna stop beating up on the
external and i got to deal with the
internal yeah it's not about your salary
it's about the significant contribution
you make you know
whether you're making a median salary in
the united states for a teacher sixty
thousand dollars but i
dare you to find more more valuable
significant people in the workforce than
teachers who craft young people
you know and and so the idea here is is
that when you begin to see
that there's a reason why at some point
in your life no matter where you're from
what
politics you ascribe to what your
spiritual experience is what country you
live in
at some point everybody lays awake at
night and says why am i here
well where's that coming from like
nobody has to teach a kid to say no
nobody has to teach a kid to ask a
million questions
and nobody ever teaches you hey at some
point
at three in the morning when you're
awake ask yourself why am i here
or what should i do in my life am i
right yeah so
that to me is a soul craving a soul
craving
to be significant now you are
significant you're significant as you're
a human being and you were created in
the eyes of god so you're significant
but there's a soul craving to be
significant for somebody else
that's what i'm saying and i think a way
to do that
is through your work it's not all about
your work
that's why i said it's relational
purpose and professional purpose
you're a student of history so how did
we get here to where my life
is all about me because what you're
saying is right
it's when i when i work with people with
strong mental health if i can get them
to just shift the perspective
that your life's about service
and if somebody can get there it's game
changer that's it that's right that's
right exactly when i can get a husband
and a wife to have a
competition to see who can serve each
other the most yeah
you talk the entire family system
changes right now
what happened where did we go sideways
because we this is wired into us
you see primates picking bugs off each
other in the
you know in the wild where did we
and i'll just say the united states
where do we get sideways and say no
this is about me i can solve me yeah i
want to
i want to say that i don't think this is
an american problem but we we grow up as
americans and we hear rugged
individualism so
the roots of of the rugged individualism
statement is the answer to this question
okay so i don't think it's an american
thing i think it is a
i think it is a prosperity thing i mean
when you talk about countries that are
that are that are prosperous so yet
third world countries
i've been privileged to be in the
poorest parts of haiti
i've been privileged to spend time in
the jungle
of africa where there's no electricity
yeah you don't see this kind of stuff
over there
you just don't so what has happened is
over time in history there's the natural
human inclination to
progress and to make progress so it's
okay to want
to accomplish all right well when when
we saw
commerce begin to modernize and this is
a
i'm trying not to give a long-winded
answer no that's what i'm asking i know
you're a history guy well the historical
context is you go from this colonial era
to now we go to more of a modern
commerce era
so as money and commerce became more
about
stuff as opposed to livelihood so for
instance
we were solving for lunch and now we're
solving for which couch do we want so i
know kelly's back there she's my fellow
history nerd
uh i grew up a little house on the
prairie so to illustrate what i'm saying
there was a point in american history i
can't speak to the world history but
in american history there's a point
where where work was about
eggs yeah food and you didn't get
dollars and cents as much commerce was
new
okay you just look at the country of
america so we took it 1776 is when they
go
we're independent but there was no
commerce there wasn't this
money system so i don't want to
completely nerd out but over time when
we begin to see
modernization of commerce and i can get
more
stuff whereas before it was all about
livelihood in the basics now it became
about stuff
will you stick the opportunity for
humans to progress
and it's stuff that makes my life more
convenient my life more luxurious
there's where it all comes from so then
now work became
less about the craft and it became about
accumulation
getting more stuff yeah because the the
silversmith and the blacksmith
like they they did the craft not because
it was passion
right it was we gotta live and if i go
do
this many horseshoes i'm gonna get
chickens and eggs gotcha well then when
commerce comes in it's just the natural
huma i hate to say it but it is the
human condition when you introduce
commerce
so then work slowly becomes about
accumulation of
money we still have the basic needs that
the blacksmith
and the little house and the prairie
people had but now it's like well the
more of this money i get i can do
more than just provide so work became
over time
a utilitarian function to live
first then to live better to live
really really good yeah and we got
twisted on it so it all became
that now the last piece on this then
then the uh
and because of ramsey solutions people
go think i'm up to this but this is the
truth
in the 50s the pell grant came out this
is post world war ii
so the pell grant comes out and higher
education is starting to become a thing
they made it accessible for people and
the federal government hmm we didn't
have anything to do with all those
veterans coming home nothing to do let's
send them back and train them
so then the pell grant became popular
the federal government went hmm we can
actually make money off of this
and here comes sally may here comes the
federal student loan program
so now it became a marketing message hey
you really want to be successful you
want a different life for your kids
than you had on the assembly line fred
maude
send your kid to college it became a
marketing message that the only way to
success
real success monetary stuff success
is through higher education that was the
fuel already on top of the fire that's
my take
i was coaching somebody the other day
and they made a statement they said hey
i'm struggling with parenting this is a
private call
struggling with my kid and
they made a statement by the way i've
known since
this that since my kid was little
they'll have a job with the name on
their shirt
so there's no illusions here and i said
whoa whoa whoa
that's okay and the parent was like yeah
i know it's okay it's great
i'm excited for it it's something
they're passionate about whatever but
just the idea that we've got to
delineate that
yeah that there's some sort of hey just
so you know we're not dealing with full
firepower here and i want to say man the
smartest guy i've ever met in my life is
gus menendez who fix any car on planet
earth couple things on that number one
um that's okay if that's true we don't
know if that's true for that father to
assume that and that's what he's doing
is he's falling into the class system
it's a class system and it's based on
economics
and that's where all of this became a
thing where work was about a rat race
and it became about status not
significance and i'm preaching
significance
and again let me be clear yeah because
you've asked me this before
when i say significance i don't mean
proving that you are significant of
course of course
i'm saying making a significant
contribution in the sense that you were
born with talent
you were born with things that fire your
soul up stuff that fires you up
makes me want to fall asleep vice versa
right
we have a unique contribution to make
and work's got to be about more than
income it's got to be about impact as
well that's what i'm saying
therein lies the title of the book from
paycheck
to purpose do we need a paycheck yes yes
we need income
but i think people want more than income
yeah
absolutely so we're going to show them
seven stages in the book where we unpack
a very clear path
or how we a figure out what is what are
all the different types of work
that are very significant to me
and because it's significant to me it'll
be significant to others what is that
role that
that dream job or multiple dream jobs by
the way
then how do we get there so anyway uh it
comes from a deep longing that i just
know that this whole
nine to five race and this whole i need
more stuff
work has been corrupted let's just say
won't you look at these
diseases of despair you look at the
we're paying it we're paying a cost for
it i'm glad to see somebody get into the
into the missional part of work
somebody's got to deal with it man and i
think now i've got we got a generation
of young people who's putting their
entire
identity in identity and work it's true
but i will tell you we see that with the
millennials but i really am encouraged
by what i'm seeing out of ginseng yeah
they're saying i'm out man
well they're crazy relationship because
they're the digital they're the kids
that
grew up with a phone their whole life
they don't even know what it's like
to not have a smartphone in their pudgy
little hands but they're sick of it
they are sick of it i love it